last night the president made what will
be one of the most important decisions
of his presidency he nominated judge
Brett Kavanaugh to the United States
Supreme Court
take a look what matters is not a
judge's political views but whether they
can set aside those views to do what the
law and the Constitution require I am
pleased to say that I have found without
doubt such a person throughout legal
circles he is considered a judges judge
a true thought leader among his peers
he's a brilliant jurist with a clear and
effective writing style universally
regarded as one of the finest and
sharpest legal minds of our time there
is no one in America more qualified for
this position and no one more deserving
now the president has now placed his
full faith behind judge Kavanagh to
carry out his all-important promise to
send a constitutionalist an originalist
judge to the highest court in the land
and during the announcement while Judge
Cavanaugh gave us a glimpse into what is
his judicial philosophy let's take a
look at that my judicial philosophy is
straightforward a judge must be
independent and must interpret the law
not make the law a judge must interpret
statutes as written and a judge must
interpret the Constitution as written
informed by history and tradition and
precedent what you just heard is a very
different philosophy than the judicial
activism that Hillary Clinton and the
Democrats love and cherish now judge
Kavanagh his record is long his
background impeccable his academic
record is off the charts his philosophy
seems extraordinarily intelligent very
sound educated at Yale he clerked for
the outgoing Justice Anthony Kennedy he
worked in the office of Solicitor
General he served as an associate
counsel in the office of the Independent
Counsel Ken Starr he was also a senior
associate counsel to President George W
Bush he argued cases before the Supreme
Court
he taught courses at Harvard and
Yale and Georgetown and Notre Dame and
his opinions have been extensively
published in academic journals and he
has served in the powerful US Court of
Appeals for the DC Circuit for more than
a decade where his opinions were often
endorsed by the United States Supreme
Court in 2016 during a speech at George
Mason University Cavanaugh spoke
extensively about the importance of
constitutionalism and he he preys upon
the late Justice Antonin Scalia he said
what did Justice Scalia stand for as a
judge it's not complicated but it is
profound and worth repeating often that
the judge's job is to interpret the law
not to make the law or make policy now
remember the structure of the
Constitution separation of powers
federalism are not mere matters of
etiquette or architecture but are at
least as essential to protecting
individual liberty as the individual
rights guaranteed in that text now this
is the exact language you'd want to hear
if you want an originalist on the court
and frankly from any judge in America
that is what every judge should practice
the job of the judiciary is to interpret
the constitutional law separation of
powers due process limits on government
and of course inalienable human rights
the judiciary should respect co-equal
branches of government that is the job
of a judge in America that is what it
means to be an originalist textualist a
constitutionalist by the way that is
what Antonin Scalia Clarence Thomas
Samuel Alito clearly understand who they
are and what it is they Revere our
Constitution but to the Democratic Party
their friends in the left-wing media
none of this matters judge Cavanaugh's
impressive track record and resume
doesn't seem to matter at all
Cavanaugh's fair and just philosophy
that doesn't matter because the left in
this country they want what's called the
judicial activists in other ones in
other words someone will throw the
Constitution to the wind and write laws
and legislate from the bench someone who
will even use international law not our
Constitution as a basis for their
findings but most of all Democrats want
anybody
not tapped by President Trump who you
the American people elected in fact they
were actually attacking president
Trump's pic before they even knew who it
was and they would have attacked anybody
that he chose now take a look at how
members of the left war already
sharpening their spears before the
president's announcement last night
take a look you just have to remember
how extensive the conservative agenda is
here for for the supreme court it's not
just rolling back abortion rights it's
not just rolling back gay rights it's
not just eliminating affirmative action
it's not just expanding the death
penalty I've never recall a previous
president outsourcing at least the
initial selection process to an outside
interest group the way that this
president has to the Federalist Society
a woman's freedom to make sensitive
health care decisions hang in the
balance with this nominee it is near
impossible to imagine that President
Trump would select a nominee who isn't
hostile to our health care law and
health care for millions and millions
and millions of Americans who is in
hostile to a woman's freedom to make her
own healthcare decisions for the
president it's gonna be all about the
personal connection who he feels
comfortable with in the moment so you're
saying he's gonna pick the man
so as REM once put at the end of the
world as we know it I've never seen a
president United States in effect make
himself a puppet of outside groups and
choose from a group of right-wing fringe
ideologues I frankly don't even think we
should be considering this nominee and
that's not all look at this official
statement released by the anti-trump
women's March organization after Judge
Cavanaugh's nomination quote in response
to dominant Donald Trump's nomination of
well plank to the Supreme Court Trump's
announcement today is a death sentence
for thousands of women in the United
States Oh whoever X was now meanwhile
according to reports those protesting
the president's nomination on the
streets of DC they were scrambling
literally to fill in the blank posters
with
nominees name this is an orchestrated
smear campaign so predictable so
coordinated so filled with hate
demagoguery it's kind of almost funny
except for the fact that their actions
have real consequences many protestors
became so aggressive last night at the
Supreme Court of the United States that
even our own shannon bream was actually
forced to move her show inside because
she felt threatened in that environment
and now the left is launching an all-out
campaign to scream and to yell and
besmirched and lie and smear and sander
and slander and use character
assassination against judge Cavanaugh
and by the way his kids will be watching
now watch this and remember it's only
day one he feels that the president
doesn't have to follow the law you are a
young woman in America or you care about
a young woman in America pay attention
to this because it will forever change
your life here is a memo to the
parklands students if you care about
common-sense gun violence protection
judge Kavanagh is your worst nightmare
they get control of the one non elected
branch the judiciary they can turn the
clock back in america.you decades maybe
centuries that's been their goal he's a
political animal he has been for a big
part of the formative years of his
career and so he thinks of this I think
as wow we need to make sure that the
United States of America stays safe by
protecting the president from what from
investigation from indictment from
prosecution everyone said when Bork was
nominated well the Southern Democrats
will have to go along everyone have to
listen to Ronald Reagan follow Ronald
Reagan and in the end the politic
completely reversed and the good
political vote was to vote against sport
because the case had been made against
him the country rose up and he was
beaten by I'm a Jew
democrats and republicans voting against
him i think the same thing can happen
and some of this rhetoric it was even
worse on Twitter social media look at
this former Virginia Governor Clinton
hack Terry McAuliffe look what he
tweeted the nomination of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh will threaten the lives of
millions of Americans for decades to
come and will morph our Supreme Court
into a political arm of the right-wing
Republican Party sounds like Ted Kennedy
and he sounds like those that attack
Justice Thomas very predictable I told
you this was coming
many top Democratic senators are now
urging their colleagues in red states
red state Democratic senators to throw
justice and logic to the wind they want
them to risk their political futures
just by voting against Cavanaugh now
it's important or remembered elections
do have consequences and I've said this
many many times the 2018 midterms this
November will be the most important
midterms in the history now look at
these six senators from red states that
are up for re-election they're in a bit
of a bind right now what are they going
to do senator Manchin West Virginia
Heitkamp North Dakota
Nelson Florida Donnelly Indiana
McCaskill Missouri tester Montana are
you going to stick with the far left of
your party like you pretty much always
do are you gonna vote as a bloc again or
are you gonna try and save your career
and do what is only an election year
conversion now it's very important to
remember all of you the six abuse are
supposed to serve the people of your
state but it appears you all serve Chuck
Schumer and company and America's
watching and as I said earlier just as
Cavanaugh is about to face the fight of
his life what he and his family will
have to endure it is sick and by the way
in the end justice Cavanaugh was
qualified his experience impeccable his
judicial philosophy is sound is
intellect keen and he should be quickly
confirmed by the US Senate we're gonna
have more on this throughout the show
but now let's turn our attention to
Europe the president now has officially
kicked off his visit ahead of a
one-on-one meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin and of course
an all-important summit with NATO this
is where President Trump will negotiate
with our allies that
they pay their fair share for their
national defense
we're not the world's piggy bank any
longer and sadly Western Europe's love
affair with the American presidency
actually died because the appeaser in
chief Barack Obama left office
now instead President Trump is facing
widespread protests across the continent
this is just one more reminder that many
in Western Europe prefer weakness not a
strong America for example remember
Obama's feckless apology tour that was
revered by all the leaders in Europe you
may remember a lot of this America like
every other nation has made mistakes and
has its flaws in America there's a
failure to appreciate Europe's leading
role in the world
instead of celebrating your dynamic
union and seeking to partner with you to
meet common challenges there have been
times where America has shown arrogance
and been dismissive even derisively
issues of women's equality are by no
means simply an issue for Islam in
Turkey Pakistan Bangladesh Indonesia
we've seen Muslim majority countries
elected a woman to lead meanwhile the
struggle for women's equality continues
in many aspects of American life now the
press they picked up on europe's love
affair with Barack Obama echoed his
effusive praise one headline read quote
Obama Wow's Berlin in the crowd with
historic speech President Obama goes
abroad and the world is happier for it
Obama connects with young Europeans now
compare that love fest to the treatment
let's go back to Ronald Reagan what he
received like presidents from Reagan led
the world with American exceptionalism
and the concept of peace through
strength and by the way Europe was not
loving Reagan during an early trip to
Europe Reagan was met by thousands of
protesters this happened all across the
continent in London West Berlin Reagan
was even quote jeered during a speech at
the European Parliament in France and of
course Reagan's policies ultimately
ushered in the end of the Cold War
brought down the Berlin wall pushed the
Soviet Union out of many
European countries but if history tells
us anything Europe apparently doesn't
learn and here we are today with more
animosity towards a sitting US president
because he projects America as a force
for good and strength in the world the
protest that we will see in Europe all
week are exactly the same as Reagan
faced the parallels are uncanny now this
is the greatest tribute that America is
now back and strong and actually leading
on the world stage the apology tour is
over tomorrow the show will be hitting
the road that's right Hannity we will be
broadcasting live from Europe as we
continue to monitor the president's
important trip and tomorrow night will
be that our cover at all for you we hope
you'll join us now let's turn our
attention to the deep state tonight
disgraced former FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
she has been subpoenaed to appear before
a closed-door session in the House of
Representatives tomorrow and sources are
telling Fox News tonight she does plan
to comply with that subpoena although I
guess anything could happen we'll keep
you posted on everything we learned from
that hearing also this week Paige's
one-time boyfriend Trump aiding FBI
agent at the center of it all Peter
struck will testify in public
this Thursday before the House Judiciary
and oversight committees this could be
one of the most contentious hearings in
years we will be covering that and
according to a brand-new report tonight
from John Solomon the FBI was reportedly
in possession I'll get this three
different versions of the now infamous
dirty dossier the Clinton bought and
paid for
phony debunked op research based on
Russian lies put together by a foreign
national now we know this phony dossier
was used as the basis for the initial
investigation of the Trump Russia
collusion witch-hunt and it was the bulk
of information to get a FISA warrant not
once but four times rod Rosenstein
selling the last one John Solomon will
be here tonight with a report also we're
learning that the Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn sentencing hearing has now
mysteriously been delayed again what it
is another bizarre move by Robert
Mullins which on and meanwhile Flynn is
now pleading for his case to be wrapped
up and according to a report from our
own Sarah Carter mo
so-called pitbull Andrew Weissman may
have actually leaked details surrounding
Mona's investigation to the Associated
Press that is a problem you're not
allowed to do that and as we speak Paul
Manafort not convicted of a thing is
sitting 23 hours a day in solitary
confinement in a federal prison over a
2005 tax case and breaking this week we
have more news from the house Intel
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez and he is
now calling for a probe of 42 Obama era
officials to determine the role that
they played in targeting the Trump
campaign to influence our election